I didn't know anything about this
college holder of the year
Garrett mores Michigan senior won the
college football holder of the year Wow
it's all together now how about a round
of applause Garrett Morris who joins us
now Garrett congratulations I hope you
can put this in words and it's not too
emotional for you thank you I appreciate
it no it's a it's a great honor Peeta
he created this award last year and it's
an honor to be the second person ever to
win it's all his in his footsteps huh so
how do you stand out as a holder I think
it's just it's detail-oriented so you
know just doing doing every little thing
right all the time so it's being
successful at doing the little things
right have you ever had the laces in
Garrett I don't want to admit it but yes
I had all the laces in from time to time
when I try to limit those as much as
possible and you still won the award in
spite of that have you ever tried to
make it seem like it's you just had a
tougher hold you know just just to make
it seem like this is really difficult
and you just saved an extra point or a
field goal I can't say I can't say I
have I think my long snapper Scott who
is with me right now I think he'd be
pretty upset if I did that did you now
did you come in as a holder or did you
come in as a position player at Michigan
I came in as a quarterback now do you uh
what are your other highlights there
have you thrown for like a two point
conversion you ever done any ran one in
that one against Rutgers that two-point
run mmm but you called that didn't you I
hear that you that was you saying I can
do it coach yeah we had practiced that
against that look all week we had to
play so it was between me and Scott we
kind of looked at the look and we saw
that we had it so him and I kind of made
the call at the line to run it where do
you put the owner where do you see a
plaque what do you get so I was talking
to Pete yesterday and I think he's
looking for sponsors right now for the
trophy
hopefully we'll get an award in place so
I can have something nice for my desk
when I have a real job what are you
gonna do in real life I have aspirations
we go into law school so hopefully that
works out I'd like to be a lawyer you
don't want to go into the NFL and be a
holder you know I I think if a GM put me
on there 53 I think I don't think that's
I don't think that's in my future is as
great as that would be when's the last
time Harbaugh yelled at you oh I don't
know him and I have always had a good
relationship he's he was a holder
himself so he's always bounced ideas and
technique off me so he's been he's been
really good and and teaching me how to
do this and being supportive of me and
holding weight Harbaugh gets down and
shows you how to hold oh he was the he
showed me originally he taught me all
that I know Wow yeah well it's a pretty
emotional speech you gave and I don't
know if this changes you know your
status on campus maybe it changes your
life I don't know Garrett but it's
pretty incredible and yes thanking your
long snapper is the way to go about it
as well but thank you for joining us and
good luck in the bowl game and it's a
Garrett Moore's he is the holder of the
year second year that they've handed it
out that's one of the tougher gets for
Fritzi you know you can track down the
Secretary of the Navy and Heisman
winners and MVPs but he got the holder
of the year because everybody else was
going after this kid the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience
[Music]